dui mom's in the hospital i just lost
everything holy [ __ ] i had nothing how
the [ __ ] am i gonna get out of this so i
was hanging out with my team and they
asked me some of the biggest struggles
that i had gone through in building the
companies that we have now and the
wealth that we have now
opening my gym i thought it was gonna be
really cool be like yeah i'm sleeping on
the floor i'm like hustling because
that's what i thought like sounded cool
it was incredibly lonely i was in a
state that i didn't know anyone in a
city that i didn't know anyone in a
warehouse that there was cars that would
drive over all night long and it was
like a gunshot it was like
and it was all concrete walls and there
was no ac and so i would just like sweat
and be awake and i was working the other
hours of the day because my first client
would get there at 4 o'clock my last
person would leave at 9 00 pm i was just
like incredibly sleepless i live there
my clients would do my laundry for me
and then i would shower at le fitness
that was hard that was very hard after i
like built all the gyms up i got out of
that and then i sold them put all the
money into this new venture and the
money was gone the processor got shut
down so i couldn't get the new money
that i had made just felt like it was
quicksand it's like every time i took a
couple steps i would just sink again
that was very frustrating this was like
the worst six months of my life it
started in october mom got sick went to
the hospital i flew out while i was
there to get myself occupied i started
launching gyms that's when jim lunch
actually started because i left my own
gym so i was like i gotta keep myself
occupied reached out some people in my
hometown and i was like hey you know
anybody and they're like yeah i know a
guy so that's that was like the first
big gym launcher so i had the mom thing
and then i got in a dui and then the
money that i put into the business got
taken after i sold all my gems to go all
in on this new thing because it was
working so now i have like a dui mom's
in the hospital i just lost everything
we had to do this launch to cover the
refunds from the last gym that i had to
shut down and so we got the 100 grand
from the first launch was able to pay
all of the refunds and i was back at
zero again did another launch had 100
grand that was what got taken by the
processors because they thought it was
like a regular activity i had six guys
selling 8 000 a day in sales that i
can't collect on and i had no money and
so i put it on a credit card like this
could [ __ ] go horribly wrong that was
that whole month the last day of the
month i got a processor for 50k i ran
50. the next day was the beginning next
month i ran another 50. so it was 100.
we did 30 or 40k in profit and i was
like did i just escape death
and then the next month the gyms from
january february started refunding the
clients and telling them to sign up with
them and so then all of that money that
i had made in profit the last month went
back in and we were 150 negative and i
was like how the [ __ ] am i getting out
of this because the thing is the more i
sold the more i'd have to refund was
there a moment in that time where you
were like maybe i'm not cut for this i
didn't think about it i had too many
other problems i was just in so much
pain i just wanted to like get out of it
i just had to pull like something out of
my ass that was why i had this big
belief that like some of the best
businesses get made out of desperation i
was 100
backed up i had nothing and so that's
when we were like you know what jim's
been a good run it was that was when i i
called the guys up for the next month
and was like hey we're out sorry they
were like can you show us how i remember
saying this to the first guy i was like
call up my my uh getting out of the gym
business sale selling my secrets that's
what i said i was like i'm selling my
secrets of everything i've learned from
all my gyms and all my locations and
filling up 30 plus gyms and doing
turnarounds i'll give it to you it was
like how much and i said six grand i'm
still a salesman i mean i can recognize
when something goes easy and i was like
[ __ ] 6k sure
done it was so fast and then i was like
eight and it was like yeah 10. yeah that
works i did 60 grand that day yeah so i
was like holy [ __ ] i made 100k in like
four days and that day was when like we
switched to licensing that was the lead
up and i remember like putting the money
into my bank because i didn't have like
another location to open or like more
equipment to buy like that's mine i'd
repaid the processors employees i'd pay
back the refunds from the closed gym i
was clear of everything and then there
was like a hundred grand left and i was
like i'm rich
i mean i remember a buddy of mine
calling me because i'd like checked in
with him a couple times and he knew that
i was like just going through a lot and
he called me like a month apart he's
like how you holding up and i was like
bro
i was like i just made 400 grand last
month and he was like what i thought you
like had the is it selling the
membership thing i was like no no like
selling the membership system and he was
like dude run in as hard as you can we
went 400 780 a million it's one two one
five one eight two it was nuts it was
literally me layla and i we had we had
an assistant i was it over the kitchen
table my rent was 1200 bucks and i told
layla i was like i don't know how long
it's gonna last that's why i kept our
expensive solos i was trying to make
money like that was it i'm not trying to
build a company i don't want to make
something that's gonna change the world
i was like i'm trying to get rich i was
gassing the [ __ ] out of it pure getting
away from pain i had feelings that i
didn't want to feel and so it's just
like anything that would make me not
feel that way was what i wanted to do
business became my feel better drug i
really didn't want to be poor again and
i really was getting reinforced heavily
by the marketplace that i was good at
this thing and so it just gave me like
complete alignment of just like rocket
fuel that way and then magnet this way
we didn't take a vacation we didn't take
weekends we didn't see friends we didn't
go out we didn't drink i was like if i
drink and [ __ ] this up i will hate
myself we can go get friends later i
just took everything out of my life that
was not this like what about work-life
balance i'm like people don't understand
how little i gave a [ __ ] this just like
feeling horrible and then finally seeing
some success i was like [ __ ] anything
that's not this like if every person who
ever met me at that point was like [ __ ]
you alex die i would have been like [ __ ]
them like whatever like i'm doing this
thing we blue passed wealth numbers 4 10
14 20. kind of came up for air past 20
and i was like oh we have 120 employees
and we have like a company and then
somebody was like your company's worth
200 million so i was like really
[Music]